what's up your vanilla chinchillas do
you know that when you die sometimes
they find mold behind your eyeballs
oh that's ice cold we got sexual
dioramas hot tub neck attacks and
Canadian floor babies welcome to this
past weekend this past weekend we get
that starter baby Monday July 31st you
friggin pimpled yard animals on your
honour giving you water are you having
to suck off the hose dude get thirsty
baby this Monday you got to get this
week huh
what you're going to do this week huh
you're going to hug your kids you're
going to blow an Egyptian what are you
going to do we all got to take steps we
got to get to that next level baby have
some fun while we all good to be here
man welcome to this past weekend it is
Monday January 31 of 2017 and if you're
only YouTube now some of you guys don't
know the audio the audio you're
listening to right now comes out on
iTunes SoundCloud wherever stitcher
cat-daddy airwaves something where you
can get a taste to this you can get this
this dirt gristle in your ears now if
you want to see the video of this it
pops up on the youtubes and that's
sometime late in the evening on Monday
or sometime Tuesday morning that has to
be edited and kind of put together it's
the same show but it's got visuality you
know in visuality is just you know what
it is it's whatever you're looking at
right now unless you're blind and shout
out to the blind man
my buddy Maurice is blind and he's
it's not that bad in there you know and
he said um he said it's not that bad and
it's that music sounds better he was
always trying to tell me that he thinks
music sounds better to him because he's
blind so he gets his airwaves you know
they just hit deeper because you're not
you're not encumbered by vision by
colors but different things going on you
know that all your senses are coming out
of your your ears your eyes aren't
taking up a lot of your uh your
bandwidth so when your ears are
operating at full bandwidth you're
coming in hot and so we get to that
spice straight into his brain you get
that air spice that sound straight into
his brain when he hears music and we
don't get that those of us who have
visuality but god bless him Maurice and
I'm good good to be with you guys today
man and if you're on the youtubes you're
seeing I'm recording in a different spot
this today I am in a comedy club at the
Comedy Store because I have to perform
in a little while I just got back from
Montreal from Canada so I don't know
what the exchange rate is on being a
straight mother hung in parables but
apparently it's one to one when it comes
to this cat daddy okay you know what I'm
saying I'll hide some gunpowder in your
granddaddy's [ __ ] you know I'm saying
that's the kind of that's the kind of
fella I am when I got to get real okay
when I got to get real with somebody but
welcome man I hope you guys had a good
weekend some people had birthdays this
weekend some people maybe had a baby if
you had a baby this weekend god bless
that beautiful little mud kitten you
know straight out of them dirty walls
out into the world you know popping
right out of mom's wallet
you know filling its lungs with that
with that freaking ah that h2o you know
what I'm saying that dry h2o air you
know what I'm talking about I also want
to thank they had a young lady a few
months ago I was at the Colusa Casino
she gave me this card it says onward on
it and it's a beautiful card on word it
says and I appreciate that made out of
metal hear that metal card
so but I'm going back from Montreal from
the Just for Laughs comedy festival and
man
Canada's hard to get into let me say
that I don't know if you've been to
Canada or you ever try to make love to a
Canadian person I don't know if that's
if it's the same at those gates you know
as it is at the vagina at the vaginal
and but gates as it is at the at the
continental walls there though at the at
the country walls but it's hard to get
into Canada dude I've been to Kenya
Nairobi Botswana lots wanna baby Gitmo
you know I've been I once broke into
someone's house over there outside of um
outside of Covington Kentucky you know
and and there are places that are hard
to get into Canada extremely hard to get
into they ask you trick questions right
when you get there did you wash your
clothes I'll ask you stuff like that
you're like ah and she starts to sweat
and you're sweating right there it's a
man or it's a lady a strong lady right
there at the customs and they'll put you
on the hot spot you know what's your
favorite cheese Alaska and you're like
BAM Havarti you know but if you don't
have that in you you sitting there
trying to describe cheese you know the
yellow the UM the the melted clack
they'll sing out one time I got stuck at
customs and I got locked into this thing
for about two hours with um a musician
his name he sang that song um Lettie
Rock Lennie Rock uh design-in a fire and
a burnt and not let it rock let it rock
let it rock and I think he did a remix
or something a little Wayne as well I
don't remember his name if you can if
you know that song you want to drop into
the youtubes or or hashtag it this past
weekend let me know what it is on
Twitter but he was a nice guy I got
stuck with him
customs one time but anyhow you can see
that I'm recording this week in the
comedy store on the video I'm here on
the comedy store people are performing
upstairs right now there's a podcast
studio in the basement of the comedy
or Bobby Lee was just on stage I was
just talking with Marc Maron who's in
that new glow television show on Netflix
and but I got to I got the candida man I
went to the Just for Laughs Montreal
Comedy Festival Montreal is a sister
city to New Orleans so if you like the
good food you can go to Montreal you can
go to New Orleans if you like the murder
for dessert no I'm saying if you like a
little bit of hacksaw jim duggan the
luckiest skull then you can mostly get
that done in New Orleans and Montreal is
diverse man I mean if you're racist you
can barely figure out who to hate very
tricky you know it's a tough place I
think if you're a racist to really get
specific to lock your targets you know
to Top Gun on somebody and I got up
there and I was a little bit I guess I
had some nerves at first it's in the
Just for Laughs festival then going on I
think first I want to say 50 years maybe
35 45 45 years and it's all the greatest
comedians from America and some from
around the world show up there and all
the agents the best agents I mean you're
talking Kevin Hart and his eight you
know are the best managers they're all
there
all of them they're all staying in the
same hotel even so at night you can go
downstairs and you got you know
everybody's down there party and you got
Danny McBride you got you know Cedric
the Entertainer Howie Mandel you got
Bobby Lee you know Bobby Lee actually
has never been there he just told me but
you got Tom you know jen kirkman you got
a you know Ali Wong you got Eric Griffin
you got Chris D'Elia you got everybody
and it's it's unbelievable it's like the
Olympics sort of for comedians and it's
just but you're not competing against
each other it's just more of a
celebration it's kind of like NBA
all-star weekend for comedians and that
happens every year in Montreal and
anybody can go anyone can go and get
tickets and you can go and hang out at
the bar in the evening where everyone is
and and it's just a blast and all these
networks tour different parties
and there's on the on the street there
are these huge stages with outdoor
performances and and so much as in
France and people's eating baguettes and
you got a hook at its prostitutes
prostitution big in Montreal you know so
you got that leg candy walking around
you know you got them girls with that
sugar pouch out there shaking it you
know I'm saying trying to give you that
sigh of BT's if you will you know and I
just got back from there so feeling some
honor you know I'm feeling I guess some
honor you know to be a part of that this
weekend and it gets to see I mean I had
I had a lunch the other day with my
buddy Steve Byrne and Dave Attell
you know David tells considered the
greatest joke writer of all time and
just to get to spend time around him and
you know and I look at him of course
like you know respect him and have you
know a lot of admiration and you know a
romanticize the idea of even just being
able to have a few jokes that are as
good as that man's of his style but it's
great to just sit and kind of share
experiences and just feel that that some
of your idols and some of the people you
you admire are just regular people and
dave was telling me a story at lunch he
said you know there's a show up here
that's kind of off it's off the beaten
path that's done every year where people
show up until crazy stories about Andy
Dick and Andy Dick is not a sex toy it's
a man Andy Dick is a managed and adult
man and he's a comedian and and David
and I actually got to open up for David
tell in Shreveport Louisiana and that's
I think Louisiana's third biggest city
and this was probably 10 years ago eight
eight maybe eight years ago nine years
ago 8 9 or 10 years ago I just said
those again and Dave after the show I
walked over to a strip club because this
is back when I said I didn't mind seeing
some of that you know that dancin puss
you know I'm saying that uh you know
seen a little bit of the old the titty
Globetrotters up there and Dave until
walk over there
Andy Dick and ridiculous is outside of
the strip club outside he's drunk he's
hooked up on liquor you know he got his
brain fill with liquor and I'm not
talking about a shop here I've told any
of this story and he knows it and and I
love Andy Dick and I'm telling this
story and Andy Dick had this little kind
of Hinch woman with him it's little love
of his little young girl of a little
white girl you know and anyhow it turns
out Andy Dick offered me a little
[ __ ] look bgz
you know what I'm saying that book to
the jaw you know I'm saying that buh buh
buh buh you just you think it's just two
letters but today Oh somebody's getting
a dick so you feel me
so Andy Dick offered me that not
declined you know you've always sort of
you always want you know and I admire
Andy Dick as a comedian and an
entertainer to immense levels and some
of you guys are like a he's not that fun
maybe is maybe Andy Dick I think is one
of the most entertaining people I've
ever seen he had a show on MTV for
awhile called the assistant I think it
was and hold on I'm going to drink for a
second all for the microphone because I
know it bugs some people and he had a
show called the assistant on MTV and it
was it's the greatest show ever if you
can go back and find that anywhere Andy
Dick's the assistant that was on MTV and
the show Joe Schmo the original season
two of the greatest unscripted or
reality shows ever of all time
anyhow so Andy Dick offering a bit that
BG Zenon saying that double consonant
you know I'm saying that mouth cat that
maptag activity you know that meat chirp
he offered me that meat chirp and I
denied it wasn't interested
fast-forward three years I'm performing
his treat for it again I go to the
casino I go to the strip club after and
this is a sex casino and Andy Dick is
again in town shooting something else
different films something I don't know
because he wasn't living in true what he
was there shooting something and some
piece of entertainment some footage
usable footage
and he said he offered me the same thing
that double consonant to the cup and
again I denied you know thankfully
denied though always I'm not rude about
that you know a lot of men out there you
know they you know you see these things
a man offered us you know touched a
wiener or two beef gentle with them or
to be trying to be gentle with them in
the pants and men be mean to these
people men be mean to these other men
that's ridiculous because no matter what
you whether you prefer that type of
mouth joy to your body or not he you
still shouldn't be mean to that person
they're still offering you a treat you
know I mean they're offering to hide
your your your penis inside of their
head I mean that's David Copperfield of
skin activities really so you don't have
to be mean even if it's not of your of
your liking and so I you know I denied
thankfully and honorably denied you know
cuz I you know anything's extremely
funny and um anyway I just I got to
share that story with Dave Dave Attell
whenever we had lunch and you know it's
kind of a silly story but just fun to
share with you guys now so what else
happened yeah it was Montreux it's just
crazy I mean there's tens of thousands
of people show up and they're out on the
street and beautiful women okay
and I'm talking mixed colors you have
not even seen of skin you know I'm
talking on Ching kandi Burruss you know
I'm talking you got um you know African
Aryans you know you got um the Israel
exa cannot everybody out there it is so
mixed and beautiful palette that you
really get an idea of what the world is
going to look like one day and I know if
you're living in like a community where
it's mostly white or black like I grew
up in was black and white that's all we
had but I don't you can hear the music
in the background right now somebody's
just getting offstage upstairs at the
world-famous Comedy Store
can hear that crowd cheering you might
not be able to hear it but uh but it's
happening but that was uh you know that
was that's how diverse it is and you
start to see that the world's going to
be a beautiful color one day when it all
works comfortably you know Montreal is a
very progressive City and it's it's a
safe city
I mean Canada is all about safety you
know when I was young I didn't even know
Canada was a real place you know I
thought that when I was growing up there
and I was in junior high school I
remember they had a chart on the wall a
big drawing you know uh not a map and
had America in all the country all the
cities in States in America and then a
below America it had Mexico but they
just had instead of describing all the
cities everything like that had the
outline of Mexico and then they had a
picture of a man and a cactus and the
man was drinking some liqueur and
wearing a hat under the sunlight but now
if you go up there to Canada for Canada
all they had they had a picture of a
wolf chasing a boy didn't have any
cities or any type data picture / wolf
chasing a boy and I was like oh so
that's all I thought about Canada you
know a place where you know we got very
it got very Swiss family jack kerouac if
you will you kind of kind of defend to
yourself you know got kind of like a
bootleg Jumanji
you know and cold - and I've never been
a huge fan of the cold either but I
thought that's what Canada was you know
it was a place to practice safety really
I thought I thought Canada was the place
where America just tried out safety
equipment do these helmets work sending
the Canada let's see are these floaties
legit send them up to Canada you know
does this have enough air in it sim it's
Canada let's see if they like it see if
it works for them because Canada is like
the safest place you could just be in a
conversation with somebody if the
conversation gets loud they'll put on a
safety helmet they'll put on a bike
helmet ken is about the safest place you
can go but Montreal mumble now you have
this French and
she's got the attitude you know you know
everybody got nipples on the tits you
know everybody got nipples on the tits
it has attitude buttons that's what they
got flying out of the chest and Faye in
uh in breast areas milk milk pouches you
know rib milk pouches and so we're out
there out there in in Montreal and it's
beautiful you walk down the street do
you don't even you just I mean you just
you're in that boner zone hearing that
boner zone and you just see beautiful
women I mean every woman just seemed
like a damn caramel they made out of
caramel you could eat they face boy
beautiful chewy sweet salty caramel
cheeks like you could just grab a piece
of woman's cheek and just chew it up and
blow bubbles I mean they everyone have a
beautiful tenth of skin you know that
French that kind of that K zone a little
bit if you're down in the body that K
zone
so anyways nice to see all the beautiful
people and then you have all these art
all this art going on you know there's
people on stilts I mean like a lot of
people you'll see 30 people and stilts
wandering around you'll see all these
art displays just like a man watching
television but just out in the middle of
the street like he's just sitting out on
a sofa he's I got a stepdad or something
he's got his belly out he's chilling and
there's a TV on just watching you know
something safety while probably watching
people be safe in the background I bet
they have a channel for that but I
always thought that that's what Canada
was as a place for America practice
safety and where avalanches could happen
is it snow country cold water country
and that's where avalanches could happen
and I've often I've had you step dreams
rather than avalanches you know I had
these Avalanche dreams and and a lot of
people would drink I was the one person
who showed up to the Avalanche with
urine in their body with a full thing of
urine and I don't know if we'd been in a
plane crash or train crash but everybody
else is just urinated before though
whatever the vehicle was crashed and so
I'm the one who got the urine and it's
funny you say you know everybody says
you know urine it's urine it's wee-wee
but once you get an avalanche that's
wine brother that's wine it's warm wine
you're serving you know it's all it's
only piss until you suck in avalanche
then that's Weiner wine you know who
wants a couple warm sips a Cabernet off
daddy you know and I you know I'm good
for that unless Andy Dick is serving
them then no thank you Andy Dick not
interested but I had a great time man I
was just honored to be part of this
festival and then I'm doing my
television taping so you do four or five
sets I got to open up for Chris D'Elia
Eric Griffin you know two buddies of
mine having good careers and and then
you do a couple of other sets around
town and you're just popping in these
different clubs and studios that are all
across their city you know so it's
pretty remarkable really it's pretty
remarkable you knew you're just you're
busting around everywhere and and then
the next thing you know I'm on stage
doing my television taping which is like
the place is packed there's two levels
of beautiful that's you know TV there's
cameras everywhere
on one stage I'm in the middle of my set
and I am crushing I'm crushing and this
man comes up out of the blue and tacks
me on the shoulder it's like a lit up
set and everything like you see on TV
and he's like the odd the generator
outside just blew out we're not picking
up the audio into the sound truck or
production truck so I had to stop bro
right in the middle of my set I had to
stop and man I was heartbreaking because
I was doing well I was doing well but so
that was surprised I mean first of all
it's surprising when you're on stage
you're in that zone now have somebody
even touch you because you're on stage
by yourself it's like rolling over in
bed and they got somebody right there or
they got a new animal you never even
owned you know surprise what's that
lizard ferret you know active animal
cabaret animal and that's you know it's
something scary and that's how it was
for me a little bit to have that
experience and be a little bit scared so
but I just felt honored to be in
Montreal and I also feel honored right
now to tell you guys
that Dollar Shave Club is the smarter
choice and you can support the podcast
you can support this past weekend and
the smarter choice you can get a great
shave at a great price okay go to
dollarshaveclub.com slash weekend and
it's only five bucks they send you the
razor they sing is a nice razor too nice
it's weighty it feels it's not it's not
plastic it's a metal you know mercury or
something I don't know a yard metal
something and they sing you that that
dr. Carver's shaved butter and that's
for you it's for a limited time new
members get their first month of the
executive razor with a tube of dr.
Carver's shave butter for only five
dollars with free shipping after that
razors are just a few bucks a month it's
a fifteen dollar value for only five
bucks go to dollarshaveclub.com slash
weekend it's a no brainer choice you can
buy these cheap razors that cut you up
make you feel like a you know like
you're unloved stepfather when you're
done shaving you know make you feel like
you're living in a you know and like
you're like you're living in gold
country mining gold after you shave
don't live like that use my Dollar Shave
Club executive razor with the dr.
Carver's shave butter you like butter on
your hot cakes put it on your face put
it in your cheeks
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash weekend
and I'm going to tell you about some
dates man I am in Dallas and that is
next weekend man and I need to hit I
look I guys I can't tell you enough that
tell your friends if you have them in
the Dallas area then I'm at the Addison
improv it's my favorite club to perform
at next to this club in La Jolla and
next to the Comedy Store that's number
three Addison improv it's in Dallas
Texas you're going to love it I'm there
August 10th through the 13th then I'm in
Austin I'm back in Texas and that is
September 6th through the 9th September
21st through 24th I mental era tees in
Cleveland and I got a new date to offer
you
November 16th through the 19th in
Huntsville Alabama at stand-up live
Huntsville that is September November
16th through 19th and I'm still trying
to lock down a date a month from now in
in Vancouver so if I do I will let you
know I'm going to do it this time gonna
do a follow-up this week so if I do I'll
let you know on there and I'll let you
know on Twitter on Instagram but I
appreciate you guys tuning in to this
past week and I appreciate the support
thank you guys for everything let's hit
the hotline now also I had a couple of
guys up we're going to do a follow-up
this week a lot of people call in and
they don't really have questions but
they also have comments as to you know
it's something that was discussed on an
episode so we're going to try to do a
follow-up where I can um you know apply
those apply those into the follow-up on
a Thursday or Friday release but thank
you guys for the love and support and
you can you can also always support the
album both albums musket fire and 30
pound bag of hamster bones
those are both available on iTunes
alright let's get to the first call
right here 8 deal uh I don't know I I
just had a little thing question about
how how would you deal with a stress you
know maybe a little down in the dumps
you know I've hit the best point anyone
would say in my life that I've ever been
but yet I feel worse than I ever have in
parts of my life that weren't so good
just maybe if you had in the insight
okay I'm a little confused by that part
the parts of my life that weren't so
good because you feel the best but the
worst and the parts your life that
weren't so good okay maybe now it's a
little clearer for me that I've repeated
it onward right on you know what what it
is to be happy when you're when you're
not and how to get past that thank you
well I appreciate the call 100% yeah I'm
spend a lot of my time depressed and I
spent you know a lot of time I think
probably eight or ten years
trying to sleep away feeling bad just
trying to sleep it away and I was
working and doing stuff as well but when
I wasn't I was finding ways to check out
sleep looking at pornography
pornographic you know even sexual
dioramas I knew a dude in India who was
making sexual artworks and mailing them
mailing them over to me and it's just if
you're not familiar with diagram is just
a basically there's a shoe box with an
activity inside of it and it's for me
those were sexual ones that somebody was
making and actually kind of nice now
looking back but so I'm familiar with
some of that brother you know that you
know things are going well but you still
don't feel good you know you still feel
empty you still feel less than and for
me what I try to do each day that makes
me feel good is to get out of myself to
get out of myself
stop thinking because if everything in
your life is about you it I feel like
you get sick so what I try to do is when
I wake up I make a gratitude list find
10 things that I'm grateful for
and then I'll try to reach out to three
other people whether it be a text it can
be a family member can be an old friend
just say hello how are you it could be a
call calls are always nice because it's
more real and then after that I'll try
to do a five minute meditation and that
kind of takes me it kind of lifts me up
a little bit takes down on myself after
that sometimes I go for a walk you know
go for a walk outside I walk to get a
coffee
but the gratitude list is the thing that
I find over time it helps me the most
because I think about things that I'm
grateful for
and I'm not going to sit there like I'm
grateful for myself and also don't say
I'm grateful for you know my brother
because I know that he loves me and I
know when I need a voice a voice or a
year to understand me and then a voice
to to care for me that he can supply
that and I'll write out all that I won't
just write you know I'm grateful for my
brother I'll write out I'm grateful for
my brother and
are all right I'm grateful for my lungs
you know they give me the air that I
need so that I can walk or said I can
run go to the gym I know things like
that sounds simple might sound stupid
but after 10 of those things I'm not
thinking about me I'm thinking about
gratitude I'm infected by a little bit
of gratitude and I find it really hard
to be unhappy when you're infected with
gratitude man and if there are still
other more specific reasons in your life
you're feeling unhappy I think you
probably have to share what those are
and look I'm not a counselor but I'd you
know so I'd recommend maybe just hitting
up a counselor you know if you really
cannot shake that unhappiness you could
need medication maybe you need to get an
animal do different things like that you
know get you you know I don't like
lizards really that much some people
like them that listen to a heavy metal
but but a beautiful animal can help one
of my friends has two cats that sleep by
her head at night and even though she
doesn't like it when they do that
because she doesn't have an
air-conditioner she still love this case
so an animal Simone can really help but
I appreciate the call man
and good luck getting happy and if you
find yourself that your sleep trying to
sleep it off then that's it that that
for me was a sign that something was
wrong I would it be like oh I'll go to
sleep and I'll feel better when I wake
up and it would work a lot but it's not
an effective there's more effective ways
to get to the root of whatever your
problem are so that you can just be
awake and live life and feel pleasant
but good luck man and and I hope you
feel better brother let's get to another
hotline call was about Canadian checks
let's go hey CEO this is Greg from
Gainesville Oh Greg from games down
that's Florida Gator country a lot of
Gators down there a lot of missing
people we're missing long enough
presumed dead
you got to wonder sometimes when you see
a gator if they've met each other
Gators dark artists on word I got a
story about a friend of mine Chinese
Canadian guys
your Chinese Canadian boom tapping right
back into that Montreal that Mix boy
that Montrell mix I mean it is just say
I mean it is just a you ever have paint
class and you were young and you just
lost your mind and mixed every paint
together and it was kind of this purple
color man
that's how beautiful it is then whenever
when you mix it all together up in
Montreal but this guy's talking about
Chinese Canadian did you think that
could even happen it's happening bro
truly beautiful onwards Clinton college
and he told me the story about when he
was nine years old
so he said he had a friend a tiny
Canadian guy that he knew in college who
told him a story from when from when
that boy was 9 years old let's hear it
you know I don't know if this is like
some Canadian ritual or whatnot but yeah
when he was nine years old he was
invited to this party by the most
popular kid in his class he was really
excited to go so he gets there that's
all these other boys you know like 13
boys or something like that and they
have this basement area of their house
they put on a movie I guess there's some
dirty scene in the movie and the kiddies
party it was he says hey look my brother
told me that that's where babies come
from
whoo man this is getting creepy and
risky and interesting at the same time
we can all remember times when we were
young you know infected with um with
novice brains and and novice hormones
onward I one of the other kids he says
well you guys want to make some babies
so in the next morning the parents come
down into the basement and they just see
all these kids lying around they're just
this massive pile of jizz on the floor
and so I guess he said what had happened
was my god they're all they all jerked
off together and
created a baby and then they just passed
out because they're so sleepy anyhow
that's my Canadian story
I love the podcast
keep listening you know wow most
people's Canadian stories is
snowboarding or getting chased by wolves
dude or finding escorts you know finding
um finding women of the night or
entertaining those women
thanks for sharing dude I mean honestly
they made a baby dude they made one of
those Canadian floor babies and that is
that's a new ritual I mean if that's not
a new birthday party ritual to find make
a Canadian floor babies and I don't know
what is I would love to know what the
movie is not in a perverse way I'm not
sitting here thinking about young boys
ejaculating you know but I am sitting
here reflecting into my own life of what
it was like at that time to be young to
be infected with your own erection you
know to be around other boys and
everybody's curious and scared and in
desperate and and naive you know just to
be just to be a whirlpool of all those
emotions at one time it's it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable to have
all those feelings really so prevalent
and new inside of your body
so that's fascinating man I remember
that Sharon Stone scene when she would
parter legs you know and there was just
a rumor in the universe that you could
see that be you know that you could be
be peeping bees and that just I remember
just watching that and trying to pause
it and I remember trying to pause that
movie 70 times to get it at the exact
spot and even then you still had 95% of
seeing anything had to be your
imagination
it was so pixelated it was so you know
it's just what we had been
so that's just unbelievable man that's
unbelievable that they were making
Canadian floor babies man Wow and that
takes a lot of teamwork that's really at
Salamis sounds like an Olympic sport you
know those Canadian floor babies and I
remember getting invited over into a
whirlpool tub now a child I might have
told this story before but you can hear
it now if you have it when I was a
youngster I was a young man you know
there was a boy in our town who had a
whirlpool a new yard a new yard hot tub
and he invited a bunch of us over as his
birthday and one boy came who was older
than the rest of us you know and this
boy's name was on Larry will caroms and
Larry will caroms was probably he could
have been 24 years old in the sixth or
seventh grade and that's back when they
let you keep going you know until you
had about 30 that has made you a janitor
at the school and that was that but
Larry will caroms he uh he was we're all
sitting in this hot tub because this boy
got a hot tub and first of all you
didn't usually get a hot tub in
Louisiana because it's already hot so at
that point you're just making soup out
of your friends and family you know in
the yard but we got five or six or seven
boys sitting in this hot tub Larry well
caroms is pleasuring himself under the
water and we don't know about pleasure
in ourselves because we had never seen
this activity and right before he's
about to experience you know
superstardom fireworks semen time with
his wiener he pulls it up out of the
water and starts to ejaculating into the
water now half of us are scared jumping
out of there we've never seen this never
seen this you know and then one boy
whose party it was latched on the Larry
will caroms wiener with both hands
because he thought that Larry will
caroms was dying that his body is
everything inside of him was slowly
going to shoot out his wiener until he
was empty just a pile of skin
floating around in that hot tub just
like an empty pool toy
well Larry will caroms felt this boy
latch on to his wiener with both hands
you know so Larry got scared I guess and
mail some type of you know aggressive
heterosexual male reaction punched this
boy right in the neck and man I've never
seen a man holdin on to some other man's
penis tightly and get punched in the
neck at the same time and that boy was
never the same you know god bless him he
was never the same so I appreciate your
call from Gainesville Florida this type
of stuff happens and we live and learn
but that's them Canadian floor babies
Wow
that is very interesting all right let's
take this last call right here and thank
you for everybody to hit the hotline if
you hit the hotline and your call
doesn't make it on look just try again
try again another time you know I'm
trying to get every call in that I can
and I really appreciate I'm very
grateful for you guys as calls again
that numbers nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three all right
let's take this last call right here
here we go they go what's up you
fluctuating firework are you doing bra
anybody I'm calling in relation to the
Lord I know you affectionately mentioned
Christ and the Lord and that you are
actually the spiritual individual and I
was just curious to what degree do you
practice any of that in your life okay
young fella calling about the Lord and
some people say the Lord these days the
lort you know and that's kind of slang
for the Lord onward let's hear more I
myself would say that I love to have
Christ consciousness as part of my life
but don't necessarily go to church every
Sunday and so you seem to have a similar
understanding that you know Jesus was
the man he laid out this path that we
should follow because it was kind and
love it to other people and I kind of
see it that way but just curious what is
your spiritual practice do you meditate
you pray three things or are you just a
good
person love your brother please well I
appreciate the call of the Lord with me
I have faith and I fade this is
predominantly a Christian faith I find
because that's what I was raised around
you know my father and I used to walk to
church when I was young my brother's
life was lifted up and really
resurrected at a time when he was at
some of his low points there were some
churches that and people of the church
and people that had very strong faith
that really stood by him and helped him
and took care of him so so God is you
know when I look back on the history of
my life has taken care of people that
that I love you know I I used to pray a
lot when I was young you know and a lot
of it was out of fear and some people
have faith you know because maybe
there's fear I don't know everybody
might have a different reason with it or
a different walk with it you know but
for me I like to have faith I'd rather
have it than not I get away from it at
times you know I get caught up in myself
I get caught up thinking that I am I am
my own God you know I am running the
show and when I get too far into that
space I find that it for me it's not
healthy you know it's nice if you have
somebody that even if it's just an
invisible power out in the world that
makes you feel not alone and that's what
I find is the most beautiful thing about
faith is that you have to have it you
know you have to make the effort you
have to to be willing to let go of
control and I think that that's a brave
thing to do so to have faith for me it
feels really brave you know and it feels
really hard like you know to not
to say instead of worrying and over
overwhelming myself to say that I'm
going to turn this over to a higher
power and and ask them for help you know
ask them to let me out of these little
cages that I put myself in we're
stressed or worried or or fearful it's
nice to have somebody you know and
especially you know growing up without a
father growing up absent of a lot of
male figures that were strong or solid
for me you know when I look back faith
was always there for me whenever I
needed it really you know and it's kind
of one of those things where you can use
it as you want
it's but I like to have it I think it's
brave to have some faith it's brave to
not to not be alone in a time where it's
such a me world
so it feels good to me and it feels like
a brave thing to me you know I'm not a
devout Bible beater I couldn't tell you
a great deal of stories from the Bible
you know that's not my place but I can
tell you that you know I ask God for
help sometimes and I thank God for for
helping me when at the end of the day
for just allowing me to be a part of
this amazing thing that's life whether
those things are good or bad and I like
going to church sometimes because what I
see at church is people getting together
people just being people you know I like
to see the children at church enjoying
each other's company and playing games
and running around and going to Sunday
school and it's just it's just so it's a
social place for them where they can you
know where we're trying to keep some of
the dark arts out of our veins and just
trying to inspire them to not feel alone
and I wish that you know I kind of
covered those few memories I do have
from growing up where my father and I
would walk to church I think I covered
some of those and and so for me you know
I have a higher
power and and I want to be able to you
know to access the higher power better
and it's all up to me being willing to
let go of control and so it's a constant
battle because I want to be in control
you know that's my ego you know I want
to run the show but it feels nice to let
it go man you know it's like having one
of those you know there's electric
things that clean clean your pool or
clean your floor you know you can leave
you can leave and go do whatever you can
be gone and that things still working
you know and that's something that I
think is pretty powerful you know just
to know that there can be something out
there that has your back and that's
brave it's brave to not it's brave to
not get stuck in your own loneliness for
me so I try to have some faith and I
hope that my faith grows over time you
know it's a constant effort from me and
it's one where I fall short a lot but
it's one that I hope to fall less short
and and I'm really kind of caught up in
that sometimes now you know just turn my
life over to something other than me
because when I try to run the show too
much it's not good you know it's just it
just feels to me like it's just too much
ego and it's nice to let some of the
weight off man it's just like that
massage for your soul when you can let
it go so that's where I'm at I want to
thank you guys for joining me for this
past weekend today and I hope you I hope
you have a great week you know and I
hope that you that you that you turn up
you know and that you let your heart out
you know and if there's a space out
there where you see somebody needing
help you extend your hand
you know you extend a smile or you
extend just a bit of affection if you
don't need to that's what I'm gonna try
to do this week man I'm gonna try to
stay in the solution and I'm gonna try
to be of service and when I walk into
any room or any situation or just open
my eyes each day this week I'm gonna try
to just say what can I do for somebody
else outside of myself man when I get
outside of myself
and I start to just be there for other
people man there's just something
magical where where I feel like that the
world has my back because I'm a
contributing member of the good that's
going on so I appreciate you guys being
with me man y'all take care brush your
hair be good to yourself and I'll see
you guys next time on this past weekend
thank you